[SOUND] Flying robots and
CIA agents?
Jack, a man in his twenties diagnosed with
schizophrenia, paced the streets.
He heard buzzing which he attributed to
attacking robots and
he swung his body around in defense.
He was convinced CIA agents lurked in the
bushes, and so
he looked around suspiciously.
He was completely alone in this world of
imaginary intruders, yet
he was surrounded by real people.
Jack had not seen a psychiatrist in weeks,
and
he was off his medications, leaving him
agitated and paranoid.
Like so many times in the past, someone
became fearful and called the police.
Jack was arrested for disturbing the peace
and he was brought to the hospital.
As a medical student,
I first met Jack in the locked ward where
he was being held for treatment.
As part of the medical team,
I worked to change his medications to
better control his psychosis.
To make those attacking robots and CIA
agents disappear.
His stay in the hospital was obviously
meant to be therapeutic.
But while he was with us, he missed
several probation hearings for
past defenses.
He lost access to low income housing and
he was kept out of the work force.
Jack's story is all too emblematic
of those with serious mental illness in
the United States.
It is a story characterized by inadequate
solutions, broken systems.
And the need for something more.
Something additional with the capacity to
heal.
Serious mental illness though, is not
limited to Schizophrenia.
It includes any mental illness that causes
significant impairment in daily life,
life activities, like working.
It includes the brother with severe
anxiety, the grandfather with PTSD,
and the mother with Bipolar Disorder.
Think of those in your life who have
struggled with mental illness.
They are not alone.
There are 44 million American adults with
mental illness.
44 million.
That's more than the population of
California.
And there are 10 million American adults
with serious mental illness,
more than the population of New York City.
These statistics include my own family.
Growing up, I watched loved ones battle
mental illness.
I remember sitting in folding chairs at
Alcoholic Anonymous meetings,
listening to poignant stores of relapse
and recovery.
I remember patiently waiting for
the visiting hours to begin at the
residential center for substance abuse.
As much as I wanted to help, I was a kid.
Granted I was a scrappy kid.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was still a kid who had enough
trouble talking to girls or choosing a
user name for AOL Instant Messenger.
>> [LAUGH]
>> A massive, massive challenge.
And so clearly I was limited in what I
could do.
These experiences.
This feeling of helplessness, sparked my
initial interest in mental illness,
and medicine.
I became convinced that if I wanted to
help those with serious mental illness
like Jack, if I wanted to be a resource to
my family, I needed to become a doctor.
Full disclosure, I also thought the
doctors on ER were bad ass.
[LAUGH] So I had mixed motives, but I
convinced Stanford to take me in.
And I immediately started looking for
opportunities to get involved.
I joined a research team that studies
early childhood trauma and
designed psychiatric services for low
income communities.
I managed a mental health clinic for
adults without insurance.
These experiences deepened my resolve to
address mental illness, but
they also gave me insight into the very
real constraints of my chosen field.
It's true I met doctors who treated
patients with compassion and skill.
But just a fraction of those who needed
treatment got it.
And often after waiting a long time and as
with other diseases,
it's really tough to monitor, because
patients are rarely in the clinic.
I also got exposure to the role of
government.
I met a bunch of patients who went months,
if not years with no treatment,
who finally got connected to doctors,
thanks to government programs and clinics.
The reality though, is these efforts are
totally insufficient.
I gradually came to this realization,
but it was my experience with Jack that
really crystalized it.
I recognized that Jack needed more than
what healthcare and
government could offer.
To lead a healthier, fuller life, Jack
needed an additional ally.
So what do you do in the case of serious
mental illness when health care and
government fall short?
I decided to apply to business school.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was either this or
management consulting.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think I made the right decision.
But after spending many years in the Bay
area, I really grew an appreciation for
the ability of business to create products
and solutions for unmet needs.
And I saw tremendous potential for its
application to serious mental illness.
I came to the conclusion, that as business
leaders,
we are uniquely positioned to tackle the
problems made visible by Jack's story.
Every day we see, all around us, how
business can grow economies,
build personal fortune, and transform the
world.
I argue business also has the capacity to
heal.
Since starting business school, I've come
across a number of companies in
the Bay Area that are working on mental
illness.
I'm here today not talking to you as an
entrepreneur, an investor or
an employee but rather as a family member
and as a future doctor.
I want to share just two companies that
have developed products that are enabling
physicians to better treat those with
serious mental illness.
These products are not yet widely
available, but they offer a glimpse
into the potential of business, it's
potential, and its capacity to heal.
Jack's illness is not static.
We met him in the hospital, but he can go
long stretches of time, in the community,
doing just fine.
But when he has a psychotic break, his
schizophrenia is totally debilitating.
Each episode sets him further and further
back, and intervening early is tough.
Ginger IO might offer a solution.
It's a mobile app that collects data on a
patient's mobility, communication, and
sleep patterns.
With this information, as Jack's doctor
I could know when his behavior is making a
major departure from his normal routine.
Ginger IO would enable me to anticipate
Jack's psychotic breaks and to intervene
before hospitalization.
I'd be the first one to tell you that
Jack's medications are not perfect, but
he functions and he feels a lot better
when he takes them.
But he's just like the rest of us and he
often forgets to take his medications.
Proteus Digital Health,
the second company is working to improve
medication adherence.
It has developed a tiny, ingestible sensor
that fits inside individual pills.
When you take the pill, it's activated by
the fluid in your stomach and
a signal is sent to a patch on your skin.
That patch in turn communicates with a
smart phone,
which collects data on medication
adherence.
That's pretty cool, right?
Yeah, it is.
[LAUGH]
Stay with me.
With Proteus as Jack's doctor, I could
know when he is off his medications,
and I could help him reach his goal of
leading a healthier life.
Imagine what future solutions could be
designed if more business leaders like us.
Applied our creativity and our acumen
toward serious mental illness.
Imagine how Jack's life could be different
if he had access to Ginger IO and Proteus
and now take that impact and multiply it
by the ten million other American adults
with serious mental illness and this way
business has a capacity to heal.
Our inadequate response to serious mental
illness is a glaring example
of our collective failure to serve some of
the weakest members in our society.
While this failure is largely hidden,
mental illness touches all of our lives.
Business and technology are not perfect
solutions.
But they have incredible potential to
help.
As business leaders,
we have the ability to transform what is
today to what can be tomorrow.
My journey, which now includes medicine
and business, is still uncharted,
as is yours.
As you leave today,
and as you look to your own future, I
simply ask you to be more inclusive.
To include Jack as you go out to reshape
the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]